8 news now viewers helped the u.s
marshals track down a wanted man they
provided tips after the i-team's vegas
fugitive segment vanessa murphy is here
now with an update vanessa
denise for the u.s marshals tracking
down convicted bank robber arthur wilson
was a priority we ran a story sharing
his photo and additional information
viewers responded with tips now he's in
custody
we have a little bit more urgency with
mr wilson due to the nature of the
offenses the i-team first brought you
the story of fugitive arthur wilson on
september 15th by the next week he was
in custody after the u.s marshals say
eight news now viewers responded with
information to help track him down this
deputy marshal who asked for his
identity to be protected told us wilson
has a criminal history in at least two
states including four robberies court
records reveal in 2015 wilson robbed two
banks in colorado three days apart he
received a 41-month prison sentence
followed by a three-year supervised
release but in august according to the
u.s marshals service wilson violated
terms of that release and disappeared
the i-team learned the u.s marshals
received word wilson was in the las
vegas area and he was considered
dangerous
we would caution anyone to make
contact wilson is charged with violating
the condition of probation or supervised
release from the original case out of
colorado again that was bank robbery
this is something the u.s marshals say
they see frequently an individual
serving time in prison being on
supervised release and not following the
rules then ending up back in custody
denise now vanessa i know you've been
doing these fugitive segments for quite
some time so this isn't actually the
first time that our viewers have helped
track down a fugitive we've got some
viewers with a pretty keen eye out there
yeah at least six fugitives have been
taken into custody after our stories
have aired most because of your tips and
in one case you might remember a
fugitive called us saying he wanted to
turn himself in i forgot about that one
that's right yeah good job thanks
vanessa